- Bist du dir sicher?
- Wir leben hier seit mehr als einem Jahr.
Der Krieg in unserer Heimat wird
noch lange dauern.
Meine Frau liebt dieses Land
und meine Tochter hat die Chance,
hier zu studieren.
Ich plane eine Zukunft hier, Pepe.
Und ich habe vor,
eine gute Zukunft zu haben.
- Ich bin kein Fachmann, Ibrahim, aber
du kommst nicht aus einem EU-Land.
Und ich glaube, nicht einmal deine
Abschlüsse werden einfach so anerkannt.
- Das weiß ich.
- Und trotzdem willst du hier
eine eigene Praxis eröffnen?
- Nicht sofort, vielleicht
in ein paar Jahren …
Ich hab' dir gesagt, meine Familie
verdient eine Zukunft in diesem Land.
Ich werde dafür kämpfen.
- Was ist mit einem Job
in einem Krankenhaus?
- Auch dafür muss ich meinen
Abschluss anerkennen lassen
und Sprachprüfungen ablegen
und als Mediziner neu zugelassen werden.
- Verstehe.
- Es gibt Bedarf in Deutschland.
Es gibt viel zu wenige Hausärzte.
Und ich hätte Zeit für meine Familie.
Als Arzt im Krankenhaus
hast du Überstunden,
Nachtschichten. Das ist anstrengend, Pepe.
- Das glaube ich.
- Ich muss mich um sehr
viele Dinge kümmern
und hoffen, dass mein
Abschluss anerkannt wird.
Dann muss ich
Sprachprüfungen ablegen und
vielleicht weitere Prüfungen absolvieren.
Das kostet viel Zeit und Geld.
Und in dieser Zeit,
da kann ich nicht
voll arbeiten, um das Geld
für meine Familie zu verdienen.
- Irgendwie muss die Miete gezahlt werden.
Was du brauchst, ist ein Kredit …